recently i was invited onto a podcast by
dr simon southerton he is a geneticist
he is doing some science outreach to
mormons the mormon stories podcast
outreach like this i feel is really
important because a lot of times
people who are highly religious don't
often have a chance to get exposed to
science in the way that other groups of
people do members of the mormon church
the church of jesus christ of latter-day
saints typically are pretty well
educated but oftentimes there is
hesitation among church members to learn
about things like evolution origin of
life research and secular scientific
explanations for the formation of
planets and stars and so on i was
invited to come on and talk about the
origin of life
with
dr william m white
this guy
is an extremely
decorated scientist i suppose you could
say he's had a long career studying the
formation of our planet he's authored
several books on geology and on
radiometric dating i was very honored to
be able to do a tag team lesson with him
there is a link down in the video
description for you to see the entire
podcast but i just wanted to share two
little clips with you one from bill from
dr william white where he describes how
stars and planets form how our planet
formed the second clip is my part where
i go into origin of life research
without further ado here is dr william
white
explaining how stars and then planets
form
floors form
in gas-rich regions one of which at
least in the if you're in the northern
hemisphere
and in the winter sky you can see the
constellation orion at night looks like
a kite it's actually a saber but i think
of the tail and it's kite if you look
down it's the second star down
it's fuzzy
because it's not a store it's a nebula
it's a it's a region of
dense gas
where stars are forming so you get these
regions of dense gas that are sort of
semi-stable because the gas is turbulent
and these sorts of things but there's a
whole lot of gravity in here so parts of
the gas start to collapse and under
themselves under gravity the gas begins
to spin
pulls itself tighter and tighter into a
star
and also with a basically
you could think of it sort of as a as a
ring sort of like saturn about it except
not not really a ring it's actually a a
disc of gas at that point
and we can see with hubble space
telescope
looking into that that orion nebula you
can actually see these stars being born
these regions with this gas disc in some
cases a star just beginning to peek out
through that dense
disk of gas
and almost all the matter in this
spinning disc of gas gets ultimately
pulled in to form the star but not all
of it
and the leftovers form planets
and in some cases i've been
we did this i think it's the star beta
pictoris
we can actually see
a planet looks like it's beginning to
carve out a clearing in the disc
and the inner parts of these discs are
very hot because they're being
compressed as the gas is being pulled
out there's radiation from the new stars
starting to heat everything up too so
they're very hot well planets in the
inner part of these
discs
like the earth mars venus mercury
end up with
not very much gas remember that
everything in the universe is mostly
hydrogen helium and then following
that's oxygen and
and carbon things that form gases inner
planets don't get their share of these
gases so they're mostly rocky and iron
the outer ones where things were cooler
uh you could get water ice to condense
out around
the orbit of jupiter that allowed those
planets to grow more rapidly because the
you know ice particles are basically
dust they're solid
uh they pull together a gas and you form
these outer planets
uh much earlier so so basically that's
how it happens the sun itself is mostly
hydrogen and helium is that because
those particles have less inertia so
they're able to collapse into the star
while the other things get left behind
or is the sun itself also made of the
same stuff that earth is but also just a
bunch of gas the reason is that hydrogen
helium don't condense very well okay
it's not a matter of momentum the cloud
of gas and dust that ultimately formed
the solar system basically had the
composition of the sun because almost
all the mass of the solar system's in
the sun it's just in the inner planets
because these gases don't condense into
solids things like hydrogen helium
carbon is mostly carbon monoxide uh most
of the oxygen well the oxygen actually
does convince condensed to form
silicates
um but nitrogen doesn't condense either
so we end up with not our share of these
gaseous things these elements we're
ended up with things like silicates and
and calcium magnesium iron these heavier
elements that like to form solids on the
outer part of the solar system where
things are cooler jupiter
almost has the same composition of the
sun it's a little richer in
the sun
it's a little richer in some of the
heavier elements but it's got almost its
full share of the nebular gas that was
formed but the inner planets
we just got the things that condense it
at high temperature
that's interesting and and we're still
leaking off helium and hydrogen
that escapes right
yes particularly helium hydrogen most of
the hydrogen in the atmosphere is tied
up in these waters but we are leaking
helium as it turns out
that clip from dr white's presentation
was awesome he gave us a bird's eye view
of
how our star or the the sun and our
solar system formed from a cloud of
elements formed by exploding stars which
were formed by the big bang
that model of course will be updated as
new information is discovered but
scientists are pretty
confident that we do understand at least
the basic outline of how our solar
system formed
now we're going to move on to something
a little bit less well understood
the origin of life
this cell here this is mycoplasma
mycoides
this thing is one of the simplest
organisms on the planet this is an
illustration by david goodsell and he
does these amazing illustrations where
he he's showing you all of the macro
molecules
so like water molecules and stuff he
ignores but so these we're seeing the
the dna is in yellow here these yellow
strings you have the ribosome which is
the thing that translates genes into
protein those are the uh globs in pink
there
and then there's little little pink
strings coming out of those globs those
are are going into those globs those are
chains of rna
this is one of the simplest organisms on
our planet now you have you have other
things that a lot of people consider to
be alive like viruses and even viroids
which are far simpler than this but they
depend on a cell that's at least this
complicated in order to reproduce kind
of cheating to say that they represent
truly simpler forms of life i mean this
is
basically as simple as we can go this is
an independent living organism so the
virus is cheap by hacking into these
cells and exploiting their inner
workings yeah so covered covert is not a
it's a cheating organism right right
it's not it can't reproduce itself
yeah
yeah it needs it needs us to to
reproduce i suppose you could say we're
cheating too because we uh we have to
eat stuff we have to eat other organisms
to survive but plants there are lots of
plants that are you could say
nearly fully independent because they're
photosynthesizing they do they do need
like nitrogen fixation which they get
from bacteria and so on but
the
the big mystery for the origin of life
is how on earth did you get something
this complex with all of these
cooperating parts
from
the chaos
far more chaotic chemical reactions and
so on that we see
elsewhere in the solar system and if you
look at a cell
so far as we can tell everything it's
just a chemical system everything is
physics and chemistry just interacting
in a very specific way but it's physics
and chemistry well how do you get
the more chaotic physics of the universe
to form something this insanely
complicated they possess and maintain
hundreds of essential genes an essential
gene is one where if you knock it out
the whole cell will die
they control thousands of distinct
chemical reactions in their metabolism
they're actively controlling those
chemical reactions they sense and they
respond appropriately to many
environmental cues they build and depend
on complex proteins and ribozymes these
are molecular machines and they use the
genetic code we do know of two
hypothetical processes that are capable
of generating complexity like this so an
engineer or a team of engineers could
hypothetically produce something like
this has never happened yet actually
we've we've been able to reproduce cells
from scratch but we haven't been able to
like design them on our own from the
bottom up and get them working and then
the other process is evolution by
natural selection
editors note a lot of times when i talk
about the origin of life i present these
two possibilities and because of that
people have asked me if i am an
intelligent design advocate the answer
is no the intelligent design movement is
it's quackery
more specifically the current
form of
intelligent design the stuff that's
marketed by the discovery institute and
so on it really is garbage these people
are not serious thinkers some of them do
have degrees and they do good science
elsewhere but the discovery institute is
not promoting real science
of course it's possible that life was
engineered there actually are serious
groups such as seti that are trying to
find real ways to actually investigate
this possibility but the intelligent
design movement they're not actually
doing any research they have never done
a single investigation into how the
supposed engineer that they believe in
actually went about engineering stuff
they have done absolutely zero research
trying to investigate the nature of this
supposed engineer meanwhile origin of
life researchers have done an incredible
amount of research investigating the
process of evolution and exactly how it
could have worked on the early earth
real scientists care about the actual
nature of the process that gave rise to
life and they care about how that
process unfolded step by step and i'm
going to present some of their research
here in a moment
we do know of two hypothetical processes
that are capable of generating
complexity like this so an engineer or a
team of engineers could
hypothetically and then the other
process is evolution by natural
selection the process of evolution can
generate incredible complexity
the problem is in order for evolution to
get going you need something that can
replicate
and you need something that can have
variation when it replicates and that
variation needs to be heritable so
replication plus heritable variation
plus selection equals open-ended
darwinian evolution and i've simplified
things a little bit here in order to get
open-ended darwinian evolution the
amount of variation that you have per
generation or per replication there's
kind of a sweet spot and that sweet spot
depends on how complex the replicator is
so if it's a really complex replicator
if you get too much variation the thing
can completely break if there's too much
variation in each generation each
replication event the simpler it is the
more variation it can withstand there's
some complications here but essentially
we need to start our starting point has
to be a replicator that can then be
acted upon by natural selection once you
get that you can get darwinian evolution
to spiral out of control and create all
sorts of complex things like cells and
eventually people that have podcasts and
so on but you need a replicator to start
with the ultimate goal in origin of life
research this is the the white whale
that everyone's after we want to be able
to find the simplest possible chemical
systems
that are capable of open-ended evolution
and how simple do those systems need to
be that need to be
so simple that we could consider them to
be prebiotically plausible that they
could have
gotten kick-started on the early earth
without any other sort of guiding thing
right
we talked about amino acids being simple
enough to be produced in meteorites
we're finding them in meteorites we're
also finding all sorts of sugars and
nucleobases other building blocks of
life that we used to think were so
complex that only cells could build them
we're finding those in meteorites
and there's a
new little field of physics that's
budding right now i'm not sure that
it'll actually take off but it's called
assembly theory assembly theory is where
people are trying to
look at the complexity of a molecule or
a system and determine
how likely that is to pop up by chance
in a specific environmental condition
the systems that
most scientists are studying right now
for the origin of life appear to be
still they're a lot simpler than modern
cells but they're still too complex
but there are two main candidates
we have cyclical reactions or
proto-metabolism so these are reactions
that are similar to what we find inside
of cells so you've got molecule a that
interacts with molecule b to produce
molecule c and then molecule c turns
around produce and interacts with
molecule b to produce molecule a so you
have this cyclical reaction
where
the molecules are cooperating to build
each other one of the ideas being
investigated
and you know some people think this is a
really promising line of research others
are more doubtful but is
some suspect that you could actually get
these
metabolic reactions to undergo a form of
darwinian evolution and
eventually give rise to open-ended
evolution the other big most promising
candidates are polymers polymers are
chain-like molecules so we saw that
amino acid earlier it was that that
that one fairly simple molecule well a
bunch of those can be linked together
into a chain what we call a polymer
and you can have different types of
amino acids linked into a chain and
that polymer can do all sorts of
complicated things rna is another
chain-like molecule it's it's made of
little building blocks that we call
nucleotides
and
we do have an animation to watch
stated clearly presents
what is the rna world hypothesis
if you were to go back in time 120
million years you'd find yourself in a
dinosaur world
500 million years ago was a world of
trilobites and other strange sea
creatures
3.4 billion years ago was the world of
the first living cells
and if you were to go back further still
scientists suspect that chains of a
chemical called rna or something similar
to rna kickstarted this entire beautiful
mess that we call life
rna is thought to have given rise to
life for several reasons chains of rna
are found abundantly in all living cells
today
rna is a close chemical cousin to dna
and with very little help from
researchers rna chains can replicate
evolve and interact with their
environments
while many details have yet to be worked
out the rna world hypothesis is the
simple idea that somewhere on our early
planet perhaps in a tide pool or hot
spring the earth's chemistry was
producing random chains of rna once
formed they began replicating evolving
and competing with each other for
survival
as these chains evolved and diversified
some eventually began cooperating to
produce the genetic code a wide array of
complex proteins and even living cells
which from the perspective of rna can
actually be thought of as houses or
survival machines for rna to live inside
to understand how rna chains can
interact with their environments
replicate and evolve we first need to
understand the simple process of base
pairing
chains of rna are made of nucleotides
small molecules that come in four
different types labeled a c u and g the
backbone atoms of a nucleotide shown
here as a yellow bar can form strong
chemical bonds with the backbone atoms
of any other rna nucleotide
this means that different chains can
have completely different sequences from
left to right the parts we call the
bases of nucleotides the colored
sections labeled a c u or g
are attracted to other bases sort of
like a magnet but they're selective
about who they will stick to
g selectively pairs with c a selectively
pairs with u
when bases find their matches and stick
together we call it base pairing
researchers have found that with a
little bit of assistance base pairing
allows chains of rna to replicate and
evolve here's how it works when a long
chain of rna is suspended in cool water
with high concentrations of free
nucleotides the chain can act as a
template for its own replication
nucleotides automatically base pair with
their partners on the existing chain if
their backbone atoms form chemical bonds
with each other and by the way this is
the part that currently requires
assistance from researchers we're not
yet sure how this would have happened in
the wild a complementary rna strand is
born one with the exact inverse sequence
of the original if the water is then
heated paired bases lose their grip
allowing both chains to act as templates
when the cycle repeats
the great thing about this process is
that every other rna chain produced is a
copy of the original but sometimes
mutations slip in
this means that as chains compete for
survival and reproduction true evolution
descent with modification acted upon by
selection can operate on chains of rna
as amazing as replication is base
pairing also gives rna chains a second
special ability
when placed in water cool enough for
base pairing but without enough free
nucleotides for replication
chains will fold up and base pair with
themselves
the end result is a complex shape with
certain sticky bases pointing outward
because they weren't able to find
partners
these sticky outward facing bases can
cause unique chemical reactions by
interacting with other molecules in
their environment
a folded chain of rna capable of guiding
a specific chemical reaction is what we
call a ribozyme
some ribozymes break certain molecules
apart others join certain molecules
together
a ribozyme specific function is
determined by its specific shape and its
shape is determined by its sequence
if a mutation changes a ribozyme
sequence the shape can be modified and
so can its function
when ribozymes were first discovered
scientists wondered how difficult it
would be for random chains of rna to
evolve legitimate survival functions
imagine for example a ribozyme that
could build nucleotides out of molecules
it finds in its environment across
multiple generations natural selection
could promote and refine this ribozyme
because the chain would tend to have
access to more free nucleotides than its
rivals allowing it to replicate more
often
to explore this idea researchers at
simon fraser university produced a large
group of random rna chains and examined
them to see if any happened to be able
to make nucleotides
surprisingly some actually could but
they weren't very efficient
researchers selected out the successful
chains and then used a lab technique
called pcr to quickly replicate them
with slight random mutations
after just 10 rounds of pcr followed by
selection
highly efficient nucleotide building
ribozymes evolved these are molecules
with a life-like ability to actively
participate in their own survival
these ribozymes and many others produced
through similar experiments are
beginning to blur the line between
living things and simple chemistry
so to sum things up
the rna world hypothesis is the simple
idea that the first things to replicate
and evolve on our planet may have been
chains of rna or something similar to
them
while the basic idea of the rna world
does seem to give us a promising pathway
to the origin of life it's still very
much a work in progress
as mentioned one of several unsolved
problems is
how did nature get backbone binding to
function without the special enzymes or
lab techniques we use today while many
researchers continue to focus on rna
others are investigating alternative
molecules chemical systems that might
replicate and evolve without assistance
and could have given rise to rna
continual breakthroughs are being found
in both avenues of research
i'm john perry
and that's the rna world hypothesis
stated clearly
well there you have it folks that's it
for my little clip here down in the
video description i have a link to the
entire podcast we talk about a lot more
stuff we talk about big bang dr white
goes over what degree of certainty do we
really have about the things that we
think we know about the big bang which
is a really interesting part that i
didn't show here it's great go check it
out the first chunk of it is going over
mormon theology which might not be super
interesting to all viewers so i've got a
link also that starts with when the
science stuff starts so look for that
down in the video description it's
labeled you'll see it enjoy